Ça a presque pas changé, c'est fou !
J'ai tellement de souvenirs sur cette place, c'est...
Et tu vois, ma grand-mère elle vivait juste là.
Attends, attends..
De quoi ?
Tu voulais que je filme pour tes parents.
Ah oui, c'est vrai.
Alors, salut beau-papa, salut belle-maman.
Donc avec Laura on est sur la place de vos vacances.
Donc elle me fait la petite visite nostalgique et je vous en fais profiter.
Vas-y.
Donc ma grand-mère, elle vivait juste là.
Mais c'est ici qu'on se retrouvait tous les soirs.
Il y avait deux grandes tables, c'était hyper convivial.
Qu'est ce qu'on a pu rigoler.
Et là, c'était sur cette place
qu'il y avait plein de gens qui passaient avec des crêpes.
Et ma tante, au lieu de leur dire "Bon appétit"...
Elle leur disait "Bande d'abrutis !".
Tu m'écoutes ?
Ouais, ouais.
Personne s'en rendait compte,
ils répondaient "Merci, vous aussi".
Attends, qui ça "ils" ?
De quoi elle parle déjà ?
Et un jour, il y a un gars qui connaissait le truc.
On s'est dit " Ohh".
Qui connaissait quel truc ?
Mais qu'est-ce qu'il te prend de pas l'écouter, putain !
Elle est là, elle te parle, ça t'intéresse en plus !
Ma soeur, elle savait que le gâteau il allait arriver.
Sa soeur ? Ok.
Un gâteau. Ok, allez.
Maintenant t'as plus qu'à l'écouter, tranquille.
Et bah voilà.
C'est pas sorcier, bordel.
La honte, elle s'était assise sur les genoux d'une inconnue.
Hein ?!
Mais de quoi elle parle ?!
Mais j'étais pas du tout en train de l'écouter !
Merde !
Ça va, Romain ?
Ouais, non, je me sens pas très bien.
Est-ce que je peux aller à l'infirmerie ?
À l'infirmerie ?
Ah j'ai dit ça ?
Oui.
Non, je voulais dire aux toilettes.
Je vais juste me passer un petit coup d'eau sur le visage, je reviens.
Ok.
Putain, je me fous dans la merde tout seul, c'est pas possible.
Alors, salut beau-papa, salut belle-maman.
Ma soeur, elle savait que le gâteau il allait arriver.
Donc elle y va en courant.
Et en revenant, elle s'assoit sur les genoux de ma mère...
Et là elle voit qu'il y a pas de gâteau, alors elle dit :
"Bah attends, il est où le gâteau ?"
Et là, elle se rend compte
qu'elle s'était pas assise à la bonne table.
La honte, elle s'était assise sur les genoux d'une inconnue.
On était morts de rire.
Yes !
Moi une fois en vacances, j'ai pris la main de ma mère
et en fait c'était pas ma mère, pareil c'était une inconnue.
La honte.
Ça va mieux, toi ?
Ouais.
T'as d'autres anecdotes à raconter ?
Je suis tout ouïe.
Un jour, on était avec ma soeur...
Et elle nous dit...
Yes !
Vraiment très, très loin, tout au bout de l'horizon,
on pouvait voir la statue de la liberté.
Tu m'écoutes ?
Ouais, ouais.
Ok.
Une fois ici, on a trouvé un porte-feuille avec ma soeur.
Il y avait 4000 euros dedans.
Du coup, on a été aux putes.
Direct.
C'est ici que ma soeur a mis un coup de tête à Alain Delon.
Bon délire.
Attends quoi ?
C'est là qu'avait eu lieu le tournage de l'émission pyramides.
Tu m'écoutes ?
Ouais, ouais.
Oh merde.
C'est ici que Christophe Colomb a découvert l'Amérique.
C'est ici que j'ai défenestré une chèvre.
C'est ici que j'ai vomi un allemand.
Tu m'écoutes ?
Ouais, ouais.
Et enfin, soyons sérieux deux minutes.
C'est ici que je t'ai annoncé que je te quittais.
Et que je rentrais à Annecy.
Quoi ?
Ben oui mec, t'es insupportable à jamais m'écouter,
moi j'en peux plus.
Non...
Laura !
Et c'est ici que j'arrête de te torturer.
Mais non je suis pas vraiment partie, Romain.
J'ai été à l'hôtel faire un aller-retour pour chercher ma veste.
Je te l'ai dit mais j'imagine que t'as pas écouté.
Faut pas que tu te mettes la pression comme ça, Romain.
Je sais que je parle beaucoup.
Donc si tu décroches, tu me le dis, c'est pas grave.
Et allez...
Je profite d'avoir ton attention pour te dire quelque chose
que j'ai pas l'habitude de te dire en face.
Je t'aime, Romain.
Tu m'écoutes ?
Ouais, ouais.